Це один з центральних районів Берліна.
Поруч Александерплац і найвища споруда Німеччини - Берлінська телевежа.
Паркуватися тут можна, не лише сплативши у паркоматі або через мобільний застосунок,
а й маючи ось такий дозвіл на паркування для місцевого жителя.
Якщо ви мешкаєте, приміром, у цьому будинку, ви маєте право під ним паркувати своє авто.
Місцевий житель може подати заявку на ось такий дозвіл для паркування і потім до двох років паркуватися.
Дворічний дозвіл на паркування для жителя Берліна коштує 20 євро 40 центів.
Загалом же за парковку в німецькій столиці залежно від району доведеться сплатити від 1 до 3 євро за годину.
Берлін розбито на 44 парковочні зони. Це 29-та.
Паркуватися вздовж вулиць безкоштовно тут можна лише до 9 ранку.
А потім до опівночі за це треба сплатити через паркомат чи онлайн або мати дозвіл на паркування.
Це дещо полегшує паркування жителям навколишніх будинків, але гарантії, що знайти вільне місце завжди вдасться, немає.
На більшості вулиць місця для паркування доступні для всіх учасників дорожнього руху, які готові за це платити.
- Ви приїжджаєте після роботи додому, а місць для парковки немає. Що робити?
- Як і всі - шукати… Шукати… Це справді проблема.
Тут можна й іншим паркуватися, але якщо ви підете на сусідню вулицю,
туди, за церквою, там тільки для місцевих парковка.
Якщо чужі там паркуються, вони, звісно, заплатять потім штраф, але заберуть у вас місце.
А це вже колишня столиця Німеччини - місто Бонн.
Підходи до парковки, як і в інших німецьких містах, з одного боку, тут схожі, а з іншого боку - є свої особливості.
Перш за все - ціна. Кожне місто саме визначає вартість дозволу на паркування для місцевого жителя.
На відміну від Берліна у Бонні цей дозвіл майже втричі дорожчий.
Якщо берлінець за право паркувати своє авто під будинком платить 10 євро 20 центів за рік, то житель Бонна - утричі більше.
Право на паркування видається лише для одного автомобіля.
Тільки в окремих випадках за умови належного обґрунтування дозволяється вносити декілька номерних знаків в один дозвіл на парковку.
Проблеми ж у жителів Бонна і Берліна схожі - брак парковочних місць уздовж дороги.
За даними Євростату, Німеччина - лідер серед країн ЄС за кількістю зареєстрованих автомобілів - їх щонайменше 46 мільйонів.
Кожен другий житель ФРН має власне авто, а в багатьох родинах - по декілька машин.
Немає постійно закріпленого місця для паркування. Є територія, де це можна робити, і вона у Бонні визначається літерою.
Якщо всі місця зайняті, доводиться довго шукати.
Це місця для парковки з дозволом у зоні О, а це вже у зоні L.
Якщо не з тією літерою заїхав, перевищив дозволені дві години паркування або взагалі не заплатив за нього - штраф.
Кожне місто знову-таки саме визначає, скільки, але щонайменше 10-15 євро.
Опале листя і білі папірчики штрафів під двірниками.
Така картина - вже звичне явище і стабільна стаття поповнення міського бюджету.
Щоб отримати дозвіл на паркування місцевого жителя - у Німеччині він називається Bewohnerausweis або Anwohnerausweis -
потрібно заповнити відповідний формуляр, а також за потреби додаткові документи, та відправити у відповідний орган міської влади.
Процес обробки заявки триває до 4 тижнів.
Забюрократизованість цієї процедури і довгий час очікування відповіді чиновників найбільше дратує місцевих жителів.
Цифровізація, принаймні у Берліні та Бонні, впроваджується доволі повільно.
Натомість значно більший прогрес у маленьких містечках.
Наприклад, у Дюрені, що неподалік від Ахена, не треба чекати тижнями, коли тобі надішлють дозвіл на паркування.
Ще у 2012 році це містечко стало першим у Німеччині, де цей документ можна оформити онлайн і роздрукувати вдома за технологією print@home.
Замість чотирьох тижнів весь процес триває три години.
Це значно економить час і витрати на утримання чиновників.
На роздрукованому власноруч дозволі на паркування є QR-код,
зісканувавши який працівники контролюючих органів можуть перевірити справжність документа.
У нецентральних житлових районах, як правило, місця для паркування вздовж вулиць безкоштовні.
Головне - їх знайти.